so if you had visited Monticello sayed
20 years ago you would have come up the
mountain and you would have just seen
Jefferson's beautiful neoclassical villa
but what we wanted to do was change that
we wanted to restore the landscape of
slavery because if you had come up this
mountaintop in Jefferson's time the
first thing you would have seen most
likely would be enslave people there
would have been no place on this
mountaintop that slavery was not visible
and we want to restore that make that
known to visitors who come here today
so we're now in the middle of recreating
or restoring dwellings along Mulberry
row that main plantation street as well
as rooms attached to the house just
behind us so all of this is part of an
effort to sort of shift the focus away
from just Jefferson and talk about the
dozens of other people who essentially
made his life possible right now we're
actually just near Jefferson's main
house the Palladian mansion that he
built throughout his life and we're
standing next to Mulberry row which is
the main plantation street at Monticello
it's about 1,300 feet through
archaeology and documentary research we
know that over 20 Workshop storehouses
and dwellings line this street there
were enslaved families here there were
indentured servants hired white artisans
and also several of these workshops were
actually supervised by Jefferson and
members of his white family so this was
really the hub of Industry of Monticello
which wasn't just this mountaintop but
was a 5,000 acre plantation and that is
about eight square miles so this
plantation is enormous but the center of
activity is really right here so if you
had been here in Jefferson say you would
have seen carriages coming up and down
this road you would have heard the noise
of chickens of dogs you would have
smelled smoke in the air you would have
heard hammers and saws there were dozens
of people here white and black free and
enslaved all working for Jefferson's
plantation from Jefferson's copious
record taking we know that he owned 607
human beings in his lifetime but at any
given time a hundred and thirty two
hundred and forty slaves would have been
working at Monticello and that would
have been not just this mountaintop but
the surrounding farms as well but this
was a tremendously dynamic and fluid
place where enslaved people were coming
and go
living in different areas and Jefferson
interacted with all of them in different
ways
but it wasn't like he was isolated here
on his mountaintop you know he used to
take daily rides throughout his
plantation not only to kind of remind
slaves that he was their owner but also
so he he had a kind of knowledge of what
was going on across these eight square
miles so mulberry Row was an experiment
for Jefferson this plantation Street was
very unique in the larger context of
Virginia plantations he wanted it to be
an experiment as a way to kind of reform
slavery and he wanted to do that by
imparting trades to enslave people so
rather than them just being field
laborers unskilled field laborers they
could come up here and learn a skill
blacksmithing carpentry house joining
these are just a few of the many skills
that enslaved people learned and
Jefferson considered this an improvement
over being out in the fields with wheat
or tobacco or the other crops if you
come here and you know that Jefferson is
the author of the Declaration the iconic
words all men are created equal and you
find out that he owned 600 slaves he
looks pretty bad but I think in
Jefferson's mind he wasn't a hypocrite
because he believed that he was making
changes to the institution of slavery
that would pave the way for its
abolition so in other words he's trying
to reform it alleviate material
conditions he's changing housing and he
believes that this is a gradual process
that will inevitably result in
emancipation further down the line we
know more about Monticello than any
other plantation in North America it's
the best documented estate and because
of that we know more about the enslaved
people here than anywhere else and I
think we've been able to put together
the most comprehensive portrait of life
for enslaved people during Jefferson's
time but
and it as well and I think that really
lends a unique and human portrait to
what slavery was here both as a horrific
and coercive institution but also as a
way of emphasizing the humanity of
enslaved people and the fact that they
were they were able to preserve
themselves and there's families even
within the bounds of enslavement Sally
Hemings was part of a very large family
of enslaved people here at Monticello
who numbered about 80 people and she was
the daughter of the Hemings matriarch
Elizabeth Hemings and we do believe that
years after his wife's death Jefferson
fathered six children with Sally Hemings
four of whom survived to adulthood
their names were estin Madison Beverly
and Harriet so Sally Hemings was part of
an inheritance I think it's really
important to remember that slaves were
property and they could be inherited
through marriage as well as being bought
and sold so when Jefferson married his
wife Martha in 1772 she was the daughter
of a very wealthy slave trader called
John Wales and it was through John Wales
that Jefferson inherited 135 slaves and
Sally Hemings was one of those slaves so
she was not born at Monticello she was
actually born on the Eastern Shore and
she arrived here in about 1773 or 1774
Sally Hemings this person who sort of
shrouded in mystery because we know so
little about her there are actually only
four references to her to descriptions
of her that exists in the last 200 years
Jefferson himself never wrote about her
explicitly so she remains this very
mysterious figure but I think it's
really important to emphasize that she
was related to Jefferson's wife so she
was Martha Wales Jefferson's half-sister
and she may have even resembled
Jefferson's wife
so in 1784 Jefferson took up a post in
Paris as an essentially a trade
ambassador he was trying to forge
treaties with the French and other
countries so that the new US could
survive in the wake of the American
Revolution but he had he wanted to have
his daughters with him he wanted to have
Martha and Mariah his youngest daughter
but he also wanted someone an enslaved
woman or girl to accompany Mariah on the
long passage across the Atlantic and it
was the young Sally Hemings who ended up
accompanying Mariah to Paris so Sally
Hemings came and lived with Jefferson
and his two daughters in Paris and that
if that may have been the beginning of
their relationship or however you want
to describe it was in Paris and
according to Sally Hemings his son
Madison she became pregnant by Jefferson
in Paris and it was there that she
extracted a very important promise from
him and that was if she returned to
Virginia with him and bore the child
that in the future all of her children
would be freed this is a huge decision
for her because when she was on French
soil she was considered free if she had
remained in Paris she could have been a
free woman but because of what we think
transpired in other words this promise
that she extracted from Jefferson she
came back here and when Jefferson died
all of those children were freed
[Music]
the Sally Hemings and Thomas Jefferson
controversy has been one that's been
going on for over 200 years but I think
one thing that we really want to do now
and the current initiatives you know
that we're embarking here on the
mountaintop is to focus on Sally Hemings
herself we want to divide her from
Thomas Jefferson and that controversy
and really focus on her as a person
because I think in this 200 year debate
or discussion she's always been a foil
for Jefferson
she's never been seen in her own light
and we want to restore her humanity so
we're standing inside of the space that
we'll be interpreting as Sally Hemings
Quarter we believe it was either this
space or the one next to it to the to
the West perhaps you can imagine her
here with her children maybe she's doing
some mending of their clothes or their
cooking you know the last meal of the
day or they're sitting around and
sharing stories of their day as well as
perhaps their past you know a typical
family activities that would have gone
on in the space
so behind me what you see is the
restoration of Monticello south wing
this wing was built in 1802 so the south
wing held a lot of domestic service
spaces as well as slave quarters in
Jefferson's time after Jefferson died
and Monticello was sold it it was
actually rebuilt a couple times by the
levee family in the 19th century so in
the 1940s the Thomas Jefferson
Foundation restored the south wing so
what they thought was its best
appearance not only did they restore the
kitchen the smokehouse in the cook's
room but they also put bathrooms into
what were slave quarters and a dairy and
so it's much of this material that we've
been removing over the past couple
months and we are now at the point where
we're restoring the spaces what we think
is a more accurate representation to
what they would look like in Jefferson's
time and we know that because there's
physical evidence as well as documentary
evidence that tells us very specifically
what Jefferson wanted so even draws a
plan of the south wing a plan to scale
so it's really tremendous evidence that
shows exactly how big the rooms were and
what the rooms were used for so we know
what space was the dairy we know where
the slave quarters were in the
smokehouse
that's all very clear but what was
exciting is that we removed that 1940's
material we're able to find physical
traces of where these walls would have
been placed and so we can put them back
very very accurately on the chimney
stack we have remains of the plaster
that we know was there in Jefferson's
time because there's Jefferson letter
that talks about asking his workmen to
plaster the space there's the heart that
survived we believe that this is perhaps
the the Jefferson era hearth where an
slave family would have warmed
themselves and perhaps cooked a quick
evening meal
there's also wonderful evidence of what
the floors will look like it's a small
detail but we really are dedicated to
getting as much of the you know as
accurately as possible restoring these
spaces so along this back wall what you
see are the the circuit 18:02 bricks
there and we can tell how they're laid
they're laid on edge which is a little
particular and then it's a running bond
and so we'll be able to restore the
floor very very accurately we've
bricks that are the same size and we'll
lay them the exact same way there's also
evidence of where these partitions were
that divided the two spaces so you can
see that the carpenters have started to
put back a sill plate but they've
aligned the sill plate with what we call
an architectural ghost so here is where
a stud would have sat upon upon the
stone wall in Jefferson's time and then
the space was plastered and whitewashed
against it and when that stud goes away
what's left is this gap in the in the
finishes that tell us exactly where the
stud would have been and inside so we're
able to put it back and you can see this
wall was canted right because we have a
ghost on this side on the other side of
the fireplace that shows where the wall
would have sat against the fireplace and
so we're able to you know even though a
typical carpenter would love to have a
nice straight wall we're putting it back
just a bit out of square cuz that's the
way that the evidence is telling us it
sat in Jefferson's time so what's going
on right now is that craftsmen from the
salvage rights the local restoration
company are putting up the timber frame
we know the size of the timber frame
members that you see from Jefferson's
documents he tells us exactly how big
the stud should be that they should be
four by three inches and so these
craftsmen have prepared all the framing
off sites like they would have done in
the 18th century everything's prepped
and assemble and taken apart and brought
on site and put up and so what's going
on right now is they're actually fitting
the Tenon's into the mortises securing
everything and then putting up you know
brick nagging is the next step for the
slave quarters and then siding like you
see behind me on the kitchen for the
dairy
so we are in the South pavilion cellar
and this is a building when the first
buildings built on the mountaintop by
Jefferson finished by 1770 and the space
originally was a kitchen and actually we
are standing about four feet above the
original floor level and what why why
that is is because Jefferson raises the
floor level in 1809 after he builds the
south wing and he turns this into a wash
house when the larger kitchen was built
to the east and the amazing thing in
this space not just you know that it's
this early then it survives but also
that earlier kitchen survived largely
intact underneath just this great fill
this wonderfully I call it great fill
because it's got a lot of artifacts
mixed into it so you know we think of
fill that's pretty boring but in this
case all of that trash that they're
bringing in with the dirt they're
pulling from somewhere contains lots of
cultural materials in the archeologists
are able to find just really amazing
pieces of ceramic and pins and thimbles
toothbrush heads it just a lot of great
artifacts that will give us a sense of
how people lived on the mountaintop in
addition to these great artifacts what
they also found was evidence of this
first kitchen any actually evidence that
had changed over time and so they've
come down upon the original fireplace
where Jefferson's early meals you know
he and his wife lived in the room above
for several years until the main house
was ready for them to move in so that
fireplace was uncovered as well as a
stew stove which is a very high style
kitchen appliance for the the mid 18th
mid and late eighteenth century that
would have lit Jefferson Cook this high
style French cuisine that he's probably
having in Williamsburg at the governor's
palace we suspected that he had a stew
stove we didn't know for sure he draws
it on a document in the 1770s but we
didn't know if it was built but luckily
enough tremendous evidence survives of
this dew stove this four burner you
could call it stew stove this rubble
sort of
in a structure down below so right now
the archaeologists have removed as much
of the material as they're going to for
this part of the project and they're
cleaning up the site for final photos
and documentation so you can see they're
meticulously cleaning behind between the
bricks and they have measured everything
in it's it's really a intensive process
but it allows us to gather and record as
much information on this site as
possible so it can be analyzed in the
future so we expect to complete the
exterior perhaps by later this spring
and then the interiors we're still
working on the exhibit plans
interpretation plans those should be
open to the public by spring of 2018
when we finished the restoration of the
south wing we hope that visitors will be
able to come and experience perhaps a
bit more of the slave life at Monticello
to understand how Monticello functioned
in the plantation context to see what
support of the main house but we're also
very very excited about being able to
put back Sally Hemings Quarter this
tremendously important person on the
mountaintop important in American
history it's important to remember that
Monticello is not just a home on a
mountain it's a plantation five thousand
acres
eight square miles nearly and the
majority of people that lived here and
Thomas Jefferson's time were enslaved
african-americans so it's important to
remember as you look at this home that
most of the labor that went into the
building of this home was done by
enslaved African Americans Jefferson did
hire several white workmen including an
Irish joined by the name of James
Dinsmore he was assisted by several
skilled craftsmen of the enslaved
community so Monticello was really
Thomas Jefferson's home for his entire
life he's born on this plantation in
1743 just three miles away from where he
builds this home he inherits this
plantation from his father his father
dies when Jefferson's fourteen as a
young man he's going to inherit this
land as well as the slaves that his
father
and Jefferson is going to decide to
build up here on this mountaintop at a
very young age you know this is
Jefferson's home his entire life
Jefferson is trying to use that
plantation to make money like most
Virginia plantation owners he has cash
crops primarily tobacco and then later
in his life wheat and he has mixed
success and turning a profit off of his
plantation but here on this mountaintop
this is also the center of his home life
as well throughout his retirement years
once the house is complete this home is
filled with his family members his
daughter Martha Jefferson Randolph and
her husband moved into this home so this
would have been home filled with the
family members as well as guests
throughout Jefferson's retirement years
as a very public official and as
somebody who gained fame for not only
being president United States but being
the man that wrote the Declaration of
Independence he would have hosted a
perpetual rounds of company here guests
would have come right here into this
room where we are right now the the hall
depending on who they were may have had
to wait here in this hall if they had a
chance to see Jefferson we have a lot of
accounts from those guests of their
visit to Monticello which for them this
would have been something new in this
hall that they didn't necessarily expect
so one guest referred to the strange
furniture of the walls another guest
called this room cluttered he fills this
room with knowledge
Jefferson sets this up almost like a
museum or a cabinet of curiosities and
he's filling this room with things that
he thinks are interesting that interests
him but also influential people
influential ideas in the creation of his
country so Jefferson had maps of all the
known continents around the room he had
Natural History specimens of animal life
in North America fossilized bones
he had American Indian artifacts that
would have been displayed here that had
been sent back to him during his
presidency from Meriwether Lewis and
William Clark diplomatic gifts that they
exchanged and their way to the Pacific
Ocean and back with more than 40
American
Nations he had busts of influential
thinkers like Voltaire the French
philosopher and turgot the French
economist he even had for Broadway
musical fans his arch-nemesis Hamilton a
bust of Hamilton here in this Hall which
he set on the opposite side of the room
of a bet bust of himself he liked to
tell his visitors that they would be
opposed and death as in life I like to
ask our visitors all the time why do you
think he had it here because we don't
know the real answer one visitor once
told me that perhaps it was a political
hunting trophy because of course
Jefferson eventually won in the
political battle versus Hamilton by
becoming president of the United States
the dining room is one of the brighter
spaces at Monticello because of the
chrome yellow paint on the walls would
have been located on the north side of
the house which would have been the
coldest and darkest side of the house
but that's where breakfast would be
served each morning and dinner about
four or five o'clock in the afternoon
ever since very famous for his political
uses of food when he was president he
would multiple times a week invite
politicians to dine in small dinner
parties at his home both Democratic
Republicans his party but also his
adversaries Federalists they would come
on separate nights but Jefferson used
those conversations to talk about
politics but also other things of the
day philosophy religion he preferred
kind of private intimate affairs where
conversation could really come to life
in the Monticello dining room there are
a number of contraptions and
conveniences that would limit the number
of enslaved people that would be
required to be present for the dinners
so the food would come in through a side
door with revolving shelves so that the
enslaved waiter is bringing the food
from the kitchen underneath the house
would not have to be entering the room
and exiting the room non-stop they could
put the food on the door outside the
room and the enslaved Butler broke
Kolbert could simply turn the door and
bring the
into the room the wine cellar was
located directly beneath the dining room
and on either side of the fireplace
Jefferson had built into the into the
mantle wine dumbwaiters so that the wine
could be delivered straight up through
the sides of the fireplace so he's using
these contraptions to limit the coming
and going of enslaved servants but at
the same time there's a lot of work
going on behind the scenes by those
enslaved servants to make that dinner
and the engaging conversation taking
place possible